un pari qui suit de près la situation en
italie 132 cas de contamination nouveau
courant un virus si ont été répertoriés
selon le dernier bilan l'épidémie a fait
deux morts l'italie prend des mesures
onze villes du nord ont ainsi été placés
en quarantaine françois szyszka beach à
codognan
les rues sont désertes cette petite
ville de 15 mille habitants située à une
soixantaine de kilomètres au sud-est de
milan est considéré comme le foyer de
l'épidémie dans la péninsule depuis
samedi
la population est priée de rester chez
elle au total ce sont plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui sont
concernées écoles restaurants et
entreprises sont fermées jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
il est clair que dans les zones touchées
que nous avons identifiés comme foyer et
mesures ont déjà été prises pour
suspendre les activités de travail dans
sous la forme d'entreprise cognitive
qu'une initiative individuelle la
suspension des manifestations publiques
de divers événements également été en
donner faux dans les zones considérées
comme des foyers ni entrer ni la sortie
ne sera autorisée sauf dérogations
particulières le premier ministre
italien giuseppe comté a par ailleurs
prévenu qu'il pourrait recourir à
l'armée pour surveiller les points de
contrôle à cinq kilomètres de la même
situation dans la commune de kasa depuis
sterling go
les habitants se ruent dans les
supermarchés pour s'approvisionner en
nourriture et pour éviter les
débordements
la police tente de rassurer
le personnel du supermarché veut ouvrir
mais il attend les ordres de leur
direction afin de ne pas créer le chaos
à l'intérieur ils veulent juste avoir
une situation ordonnée ils ne savent pas
encore à quelle heure ils vont ouvrir
signe de la grande inquiétude des
autorités italiennes
les derniers jours du carnaval de venise
ont été annulés il devait se dérouler
jusqu'à bartz